moi ma vie elle a changé et comme je dis
à tout le monde aujourd'hui je travaille
pour rembourser la maison donc là ça
s'est accéléré et je me suis fait un
plaisir je me suis acheté une voiture
d'occasion je me suis acheté un gros SUV
et bride hybride mais voilà
il y a quand même à côté de thermique et
je me suis acheté un 4x4 que j'ai pris
que j'ai pu prendre un crédit justement
pour financer cette voiture que le
crédit je le rappelle avant et le
montant de la voiture c'est à peu près
30000 €. c'est vraiment un truc j'aurais
jamais cru qu'un jour non c'est pas
45000 j'essaye de la revendre 45
[Rires]
voilà
et j'aurais jamais cru un jour acheter
une voiture
je pense que c'est une belle parure que
je vais acheter pour toi rien moi ça m'a
fait en fait j'aime bien gagner de
l'argent mais pas pour moi mais ça se
voit
offrir donc c'est une belle parure grâce
à vous que j'avais une parure à combien
bah si à peu près à peu près il a dit le
montant lui quelques quelques
milliers d'euros ah ouais ouais une
parure c'est pas précis il y avait quoi
dans cette parure un collier 3500 euros
bracelet c'est la plus le plus beau
cadeau que j'ai fait pour elle
[Rires]
non mais c'est un montant considérable
mais j'avais économisé
et je me suis je me suis bien fait
pigeonner mais trois dernières meufs
j'aurais offert des voitures
qui sont partis en plus d'autres mecs
donc là c'est Maximilien un des mecs
c'est le coin des pigeons ici
c'est plus grave parce que je crois que
même si t'as pas le permis tu peux
immatriculer une voiture à ton nom même
sans avoir le permis avant
ça fait pas que voyager Pierre Bernard
Montiel ce dont je suis le plus fier
c'est une maison pour ma mère parce
qu'on toute ma vie toute notre vie en
HLM là j'étais très fier de ça de toute
façon je me permets de le dire et moi je
me suis acheté une maison aussi
une seule je suis pas sûr c'est
sûr
c'est pour ça que tu veux faire beaucoup
de 6 à
7h30
j'ai pris une nouvelle maison elle est
un peu chère help un peu plus de ça il
dit à Lionel Stan ne le dis pas Siri
art c'est vrai c'est mon ami qui est le
directeur général
il faut faire travailler mon tien
apparemment il a acheté une nouvelle
maison
je vous jure toute l'histoire
j'ai quitté le Pilat qui était une
région que j'aime que de la région de
mon enfant au bout de 30 ans toi ça va
toi sinon
j'achète une nouvelle maison je voulais
pas le dire mais vous me faites dire
donc voilà donc je l'ai dit c'est pas là
mais je te le fais pas dire je l'ai dit
mais oui malheureusement oui oui oui ça
euh
une maison combien de pièces oh je sais
plus
mais non non il y a cachée ou pas
c'est tout
une très grande maison on pourrait
appeler pas à toi
on pourrait appeler ça presque un riad
[Rires]
depuis ce qui t'a fait c'est une
grillade
[Applaudissements]
qui me demande quelle est très grand
produit producteur quelle est la marque
de ma veste François envoie-moi l'argent
je te vois ce que je peux faire ah mon
chéri t'inquiète pas je crois que c'est
voilà
t'inquiète pas merci alors on finira par
Castaldi bene qu'est-ce que tu as fait
toi tu as acheté tu as acheté combien de
boulets
non j'ai loué une très jolie maison cet
été parce que je voulais qu'elle soit
grande pour pouvoir accueillir mes
parents mon frère
mon amoureux ses enfants etc donc ça
c'était la dépense de l'été c'était une
très très jolie maison
je fais attention
elle dépense rien ça fait des années
qu'elle met de côté frère
sur la vie de ma mère quand elle va
s'envoyer en l'air frère réellement elle
va elle va racheter celle qui marche M6
je vous jure que c'est vrai et elle
celle-là que celle-là c'est un truc de
fou les deux là Daniel Moreau et Benaim
sur la tête de ma mère chez elle si
j'avais le code du coffre mon frère
maman Ouali attendez il doit avoir mon
frère il doit avoir des billets billes
comme un ça oh je te jure ça fait des
années qu'elles ont plâtre tu reviens
c'est un truc de fou hein toi tu m'as
dit parce que tu ferais euh non mais moi
est-ce que je ferais un jour j'ai
vraiment la première fois
de ma mère j'ai jamais vu une barre rose
pareil c'est dur que c'est vrai mais
elle a racheté la banque la banque pour
aller à la plus oseille que le banquier
frère
elle prête de l'oseille au banquier
[Rires]
je rêvais d'aller au Festival de Cannes
et donc c'était il y a très longtemps
j'étais à France 2 et on lui envoie pour
faire un reportage donc c'est la
première fois mais on m'envoie et France
2 il payait le Pierre et Vacances vous
savez un truc et donc je me suis payé 4
nuits au Carlton et là j'ai payé en
plusieurs fois avec mon salaire de
France 2 c'était incroyable mais voilà
je prends petit déjeuner à côté de
Claude Lelouch c'était la grande vie
c'était la première fois donc là
j'explanqué
c'est quoi la marque de ta chemise je te
dirai dans
[Applaudissements]
c'est moins drôle là où tu arrives pas
de changer c'est vrai en fait non c'est
vrai il y a toujours sa maman
oui quelques-uns mais j'ai quasiment
jamais découchés quoi en fait
à la maison ah non alors
je te rappelle toi des rapatrier
vas-y molo parce que on va te [ __ ]
dehors tu vois c'est tout drôle tu vois
quand tu vas te retrouver avec les
huissiers au cul tu vas demander
parce que je t'explique quand tu
dévisses tu dévisses
qu'elle ramène frère
à moins qu'elle mette à monter
[Applaudissements]
je crois que Jean-Marcel arrive non mais
sans déconné
elle commence à se préparer quand le mec
est en bas des escaliers elle sait
qu'elle a une demi-heure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'espère je suis sûr que tu vas te
marier un jour j'ai eu un flash
quoi
alors Cyril vous ne croyez pas si bien
dit on appelle à mon pépé Roger mon
grand-père qui était astrologue
pepperoni
et qui m'a toujours dit que je me
marierai avec un homme avec un costume
bleu marine
le costume je t'ai donné plus vite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il était dans le tissu quoi je sens sur
la Torah j'ai sentiments avec quelqu'un
qui a une veste bleu marine
ça peut être Bernard
ce sont déjà galoches les deux
tu as une nouvelle maison t'as pas de
meuf tu as de l'oseille tu kiffes Daniel
je crois fais-toi plaisir un peu frère
tu as kiffé l'embrasser la dernière fois
non mais c'est vrai je te rappelle tu
avais le kiki tout dur mon dieu
c'est pas pour vidéo gag
dis la vérité non mais le corps c'est
rien moi si je te relis encore si tu
veux
je dis le corps c'est rien pour moi le
corps là
elle veut pas coucher tu veux coucher
non elle veut se coucher
tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
avoir votre chat ce weekend
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est que j'ai attendu une bague toute
ma vie un petit peu la princesse qui
rêvait d'une bague toute sa vie ouais
donc en fait il y a deux ans qu'est-ce
que j'ai fait Cyril
[Rires]
alors moi ce que j'ai fait sur moi
je sors tout ce que j'ai sur mon PEL
tout l'argent je le rassemble je sors de
la banque j'avais mes sous dans mes
poches et des j'avais un peu de sous et
je me suis dit je vais m'acheter cette
bague cette [ __ ] de bague
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que depuis deux ans j'en ai eu
plein
dites-moi là c'est un pigeon qui vient
de se réveiller vers un pigeon qui fume
à mon avis il y a une voix c'est un truc
de ouf
j'ai été voir Casino Royale au cinéma
qui est un James Bond et il y avait la
nouvelle à sa Martine royale et j'étais
sur les Champs-Élysées et je vois le
film j'ai dit je sors je sors du cinéma
et je vais aller directement acheter la
voiture
je suis sortie du cinéma
Aston Martin je suis rentré je dis
bonjour monsieur je voudrais la la
sainte Martine de Diane est-ce que vous
l'avez oui monsieur Castaldi j'ai fait
un chèque et je l'ai eu
j'ai fait un chèque directement
j'ai pas eu pendant une semaine je l'ai
eu 8 mois après et il voulait vivre il y
a votre nom sur le moteur comme ça et je
vais pigeon aussi
et donc et donc j'avais acheté cette
voiture assez cher
380000 euros et en fait j'avais dit en
fait je m'en savais pas du tout parce
que j'en avais voilà je vois ça fait pas
et j'ai voulu la revendre et quand je
l'ai acheté mais vous savez c'est une
voiture extrêmement rare donc je vous la
vends mais vraiment parce que c'est vous
sinon je vous la vendrai pas donc je
reviens un an après pour dire voilà bah
voilà finalement je m'en sers pas est-ce
que est-ce que vous pouvez pas me la
prendre ça se rebond pas parce que
j'ai vendu 150
000 euros et aujourd'hui elle vaut 1
million d'euros
il y a Tony le corse qui me demande la
marque de ma montre
magnifique c'est un cadeau de Maya de
Cédric et de Seb voilà faire cet été